chers citoyens de la Russie chers
anciens combattants camarades soldats et
quartier maître sergent et adjudant
sous-officier de l'armée et de la marine
camarades officiers généraux et amiro
combattants et commandant en chef de
l'opération militaire spécial je vous
salue et félicite à l'occasion du Jour
de la grande victoire
Alain mémoire de nos pères grand-père et
arrière-grand-père qui sont devenus
immortels
combattant pour la patrie au prix de
leur sacrifice ils ont sauvé le monde du
nazisme aujourd'hui les situations est à
nouveau
au tournant
à nouveau nous voyons une vraie guerre
qui sévit mais nous avons repoussé le
terrorisme international nous allons
défendre la population du don-basse et
assurer notre sécurité pour nous pour la
Russie il n'y a pas de peuple INAMI à
l'ouest ni à l'Est comme la majorité des
gens sur cette planète nous souhaitons
voir l'avenir
est telle que la stabilité nous pensons
que le caractère supérieur est
sournois mais
les élites occidentales continuent à
parler de leur exceptionniste
il faut répandre le clivage et les
discord il sème la haine Larry sophobie
et le nationalisme et la haine et le
détruisent les valeurs familiales le
traditionnel qui rendent un être humain
ils font tout pour
imposer leur volonté au peuple leur
règle
mais ces temps-ci du vol
apparemment oublié ce que ça veut dire
l'hégémonie du nazisme oublié est-ce que
ça veut dire le fléau du mal absolu ils
ont oublié tous ceux qui ont payé de
leur vie pour libérer l'Europe nous
voyons que dans un certain nombre de
pays
ont détruit les monuments aux héros
soviétiques ont
des pauses ces monuments et on fait
répandre le culte du nazisme et la
mémoire des vrais héros est un
c'est un crime de faire oublier ses
exploits c'est le revanchisme de tous
ceux et qui
préparer un nouvel assaut contre la
Russie leur objectif
et n'est pas nouveau objectif et de
détruire la Russie de revoir les
résultats de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
et de détruire l'ordre mondial et le
droit international et de faire étouffer
les nouveaux centres de développement
les ambitions
l'impunité se transforme en tragédie et
c'est ça la raison du de la catastrophe
du peuple ukrainien ils sont devenus en
otage de leur
ils sont devenus et juste des ressources
nécessaires pour des projets à
l'Occident mais non non préservons
l'héritage
c'est que nous honorons et rendons
hommage au combattant des armées
soviétiques des États-Unis du
Royaume-Uni nous nous souvenons des
héros et des exploits des héros chinois
je suis persuadée que l'expérience
et
la force de la coopération
internationale aujourd'hui
surtout maintenant lorsque le monde se
tourne vers le
caractère multipolaire vers les
opportunités égales pour le
développement de tous les pays et très
important qu'aujourd'hui à Moscou et des
leaders et des dirigeants de la cellule
qui sont réunis je vois ainsi l'hommage
à la mémoire de nos ancêtres ils se sont
combattus ensemble ils ont apporté la
contribution commune en la victoire
commune et nous allons nous souvenir de
cela nous nous inclinons devant tous
ceux qui ont perdu la vie nous nous
inclinons devant les mers et les pères
les filles c'est les filles les époux et
les épouses les frères et les sœurs les
proches et les amis
je déclare une minute de silence
merci
chers citoyen de la Russie les batailles
qui décident de la destinée de notre
pays sont toujours devenus sacrés et
populaire nous sommes fidèles à
l'héritage de nos ancêtres nous
comprenons parfaitement ce que ça veut
dire être digne
des exploits de nos ancêtres nous sommes
fiers des participants de l'opération
militaire spécial de ceux qui sont au
front tous ceux qui sont sous les feux
sauve les blessés il n'y a pas
d'exploiter plus important les services
plus importants de ce que vous rendez à
la patrie c'est la sécurité il est venue
de notre épaterie et peuple qui
dépendent de vous et vous vous êtes à la
hauteur de vos des attentes vous vous
battez pour vos amis pour vos proches
pour vos familles
et il vous attendent et je suis persuadé
que vous sentez et ressentez leur amour
éternel nous faisons tout pour soutenir
nos combattants tout le monde est prêt à
vous épauler et prie pour vous chers
camarades chers amis aujourd'hui chaque
famille
russe
commémore les proches les héros et se
rendent au monument des héros nous
sommes sur la Place Rouge sur la terre
qui se souvient de mitrydon Square de
des défenseurs de pajer ski mais Petro
et un couteau des défilés de
1941 et 1945 aujourd'hui nous
allons les participants de l'opération
spéciale militaire ce sont des
combattants qui ont participé à la
mobilisation partielle il y a des
combattants des représentants du
ministère de l'intérieur de la garde
nationale et des de la résistance je
vous salue je salue tous ceux qui
défendent la Russie sur le champ de
bataille tous ceux qui sont au service
lors de la grande guerre patriotique nos
ancêtres héroïques ont trouvé qu'il n'y
a pas plus fort que l'unité nationale il
n'y a pas plus fort que l'amour pour la
patrie pour la Russie pour nos forces
armées vaillantes
à les victoires hour
[Musique]